[Musique]
c'est un sport qui diffère de toutes ans
passés un sport tensions entre attention
préfet des lots à la glace c'est ce
qu'ont fait les adeptes du hockey soir
tous les mardis les hockeyeurs du club
camo se donnent rendez vous à la piscine
joseph charbonneau à montréal le
président du club valérie robert nous
parle d origine de ce sport est démente
est en fait en angleterre dans les
années 50
c'est un groupe de plongeurs et de
chasseurs sous-marins qui ont décidé
d'inventer une sorte de sport pour
presqu'île aura tout eu le ok sous
marins se joue en deux périodes de 15
minutes
six joueurs de chaque équipe se font
face l'objectif est simple mettre une
rondelle de trois livres de plomb à
l'aide d'un bâton d'une trentaine de
centimètres dans un bus le club
montréalais peut compter sur quatre
joueurs de l'équipe nationale qui sera à
québec pour les 20e championnat du monde
dont martin tanguay la différence ben
alors qu'ils se marient par rapport à
d'autres passent et la ténacité c'est la
capacité à rester dans le fond étant
donné que c'est un sport en apnée c'est
aussi une occasion de faire un échappé
ce présente works glace par exemple
on va le faire parce que même si on est
fatigué mais on respect tandis qu'ici
on peut respirer donc je trouve que le
mental dans le gotha du hockey sous
marins on retrouve la france l'afrique
du sud l'australie et la
nouvelle-zélande
mais le canada lui n'est pas en reste en
1986 l'unifolié va remporter l'or en
australie sa seule médaille mondiale
alors le bon faisait partie de l'équipe
et il se souvient que tout avait
commencé en 1984 on tapote ça jusqu'au
bout dans l'intention d'arriver premier
mon dieu on a mangé une claque d'en face
on est arrivé 5e en 86 on est arrivé en
australie personnes nous attendaient les
hamburgers on est arrivé premier on est
bien fiers de notre victoire
neuf gardes heureusement pour le go to
opinion revenu à montréal
alain lebeau et son équipe s'attendait à
un retour triomphal c'était sans compter
que du canadien de montréal venait de
remporter la coupe stanley ils ont tout
de même été reçus à l'hôtel de ville ont
été honorés à ville de montréal le bras
droit du bail de l'est pas il a fait un
lapsus terre et abidjan bon il dit il
était d'en voir les caméras temps
maussade exil j'ai en face de moi des
joies tu joues as-tu souterrain non
chrétiens de montréal n'a peut-être pas
fait les séries mais une chose est sûre
c'est une équipe canadienne sera des
championnats du monde
si robert frosi là le canada montréal